this might be a little controversial but
I think I prefer Stargate Atlantis over
sg1
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel I don't think you realize
the implications of this
or maybe you do
[Music]
I'm as surprised about this as you are
if I'm honest but I recently have
actually finally been able to watch
Stargate Atlantis again now I have them
on DVD somewhere in the garage
but I actually don't have a DVD player
anymore
so when I suddenly realized that Sky TV
over in the UK was actually carrying
Stargate Atlantis again I got very
excited and I realized that I can watch
this series again for the first time in
a long time
too long
good afternoon Ronnie's password
fortunately
I do
he told you his password I didn't think
I'd remember it uh one six four three
one eight seven nine one nine six eight
four two
see don't take a genius
1643 is a year Isaac Newton was born
1879 Einstein in 1968. the year Rodney
was born never underestimate the size of
that man city
wait weren't there other numbers
42. what is that
it's the ultimate answer to the great
question of life's universe and
everything
but
why do I say I think I might prefer SGA
to sg1
is that just wrong to even compare them
well I would argue that actually trying
to compare or trying to choose your
favorite between sg1 and SGA is like
picking between your two children like
trying to pick a favorite child
you shouldn't do it shouldn't even cross
your mind but let's be honest
we all do we've all thought about it at
least once that there's just one child
you like that that a little bit more
than the other one
I'm not going to tell you which one but
they know
now obviously I'm joking a little bit I
love my children equally and I love
Stargate sg1 and SGA equally you notice
I'm not mentioning SGU but we'll leave
that kettle of fish alone for a minute
but I have to admit if I'm really really
harsh for myself and I have to say which
one I would I rather watch at the moment
I am absolutely adoring SG Atlantis and
I actually think it was a slightly
better produced series than sg1 so why
do I say that well first of all
obviously the production value is better
from the first moment in Stargate
Atlantis the first series maybe even two
series of sg1 are much weaker than what
followed I would actually argue that
stagger sg1 really didn't find its feet
properly until halfway through the third
season
um they didn't have the budget I think
as creators they needed to learn how to
tell the story a little bit better maybe
and I think over time they did do that
they just got better at creating
Stargate as you'd expect by the time SGA
came along they had perfected it
so from day one Stargate Atlantis was as
good as anything sg1 ever did so let's
break this down a little bit and have a
think about this in a few different ways
the characters
I would actually argue that
the characters from sg1 this year were
very similar because I think Brad Wright
Robert C Cooper except a really
stuck to the formula from sg1 they had
that slightly sarcastic good looking
leader they had the alien Warrior they
had the scientists and the genius they
then had characters like we you know who
were caring and had a big heart
I actually think they very much stuck to
the same kind of formula even though
they tweaked it obviously we is
different to Hammond in lots and lots of
ways but I think the basic idea and the
basic formula about where they were
going with the character is kind of
similar they knew that certain things
would work for the series and they stuck
with them they played with them a little
bit they fine-tuned them for Stargate
Atlantis which I think again is
important and I think they learned their
lessons from maybe a few of the mistakes
from Stargate sg1 and saying that the
mistakes in Stargate sg1 is you know not
like same mistakes in Star Trek very
very different
minor errors or things they learned
let's not call Eris and it's not saying
mistakes Mystery One let's just say they
just learned from things they might have
done differently in Stargate Atlantis
they use those lessons and they use them
very very well
now I will say actually though that
Stargate Atlantis the first season did
need some fine tuning obviously we did
see Ford leave and we saw Jason Momoa
and his character Ronan Dex come in now
I never disliked Ford I actually thought
he was a really interesting character
but let's be honest he's no Ronan Dex
now I would equate this to sort of what
um Star Trek the Next Generation had to
do when they had to re-jig the crew you
know like when tashiyar died they made
Walther security officer Jordy lafords
magically got a load of engineering
qualifications and became the chief
engineer they re-jigged it it made for a
better show now I think with this
they actually did this kind of same
thing they actually rejigged it slightly
and it made for a much better show
afterwards but the first season was not
markably weaker than the second
just bringing in Ron index made it just
a little bit better though how about
humor I will always argue that the thing
missing from SGU was the humor the
light-hearted storylines the
light-hearted banter between the cast
that really lacked we didn't get an SGU
and I think it it hurt throughout the
series that we didn't in Stargate
Atlantis we got exactly the same kind of
humor that we got in sg1 and I would
argue that for every really funny bit in
sg1 we get just as a funny bit in SGA
power Rodney and Taylor shot me
they're both fine and uh I think kagan's
out of the woods too oh you shot me and
none of you experienced any after
effects from this wraith device well I
mean we're all pretty creeped out who's
the most unsettling thing I've ever
experienced but
we're gonna be fine
we'll check in a few hours
Rodney I shot you and I said I was sorry
you shot me too I'm sorry for shooting
everyone so from a human point of view I
don't think there's much difference
between the series I just love the
Atlantis carried on with the same type
of feel I wish SGU had
the villains obviously SG wanted to go
old and then the replicators and then
the Ori as well as if you were the side
villains here and there in Stargate
Atlantis it was mainly The Wraith even
though we did get to see some other
villains along the way as well including
different versions of the replicators
Etc
for me though let's just compare the
gold wall to The Wraith quickly well for
me the wraiths were a lot scarier even
though they kept doing all that
stuff that which was a little silly at
times once you notice that they're doing
that once you notice actually the teeth
it is a little funny
but the Drone wraith were genuinely
scary if one of those was walking
towards you looking all annoyed a little
bit of we would come out of you and you
would run away
all right the queens and things like
that weren't as scary but the drones but
I'll keep you up at night
the gold world were never that scary to
me I thought they were you know
intimidating maybe they were clever they
were a good villain and you never quite
knew who was who
but they were never really scary
The Wraith were now obviously they took
the whole Space vampires and ran with it
they created a villain though that was
very hard to kill it was like they took
let's have a look at all the monster
movies that have been really popular in
the last 20 years and mash them all
together do we have an agreement
we do
I believe among your people that is
customary to shake hands
just a little wraith human
and it worked
the replicators were never particularly
scary
The Wraith were I actually think out of
all of the Stargate villains they were
probably the most scary except for maybe
Anubis because Anubis actually did Scare
The Producers at me how about from a
logical point of view with Stargate
Atlantis cleverer than sg1 in any way
well the puddle jumpers for me were a
very clever addition to the Stargate
Universe I've always said in sg1 it was
kind of infuriating that we just walked
through the gate and you can only
basically explore the other side within
walking distance it didn't really make
any logical sense now with the addition
of the puddle jumpers the next thing the
Ancients did was actually put the
Stargates into space that again was
actually a very clever way of doing it
particularly if you want to explore the
universe but you don't want anybody else
to find your gate by accident so I
always really like the puddle jumpers
even though I think they were seriously
overpowered shuttle and I might do a
video talking about the puddle jumpers
at some point in the future if you want
me to get into the comments
I do think they allowed for way more
storylines than basically sg1 was able
to do when they just went for a walk
through the game how about the Ancients
well we learned an awful lot about the
Ancients in sg1 but we learned way more
about them in Stargate Atlantis and some
of the crossover episodes we had between
sg1 nsga we actually got to meet a lot
of the Ancients in Stargate Atlantis and
I think that was really really
interesting because we actually got to
see them in their human form they're
slightly weaker kind of arrogant human
form as well which gave them a little
bit more of a kind of human layer to
them that maybe we didn't get to see in
Stargate sg1 it made them a little bit
more real I've always argued that when
Stargate returns I would love to see an
ancients prequel series or maybe even a
movie and because because the Ancients
are such an important part of Stargate
I'd love to get a bit more of a feel for
them but Stargate Atlantis did do that
in lots and lots of different ways it
just added so much to the Stargate
history into the Stargate Universe it
was fascinating to see the Ancients and
I'm really glad we got to see them in as
many different ways as we did basically
what I'm trying to say is that Brad
Wright and Robert C Cooper had seven
years to learn all about the Stargate
Universe and how to make the perfect
Stargate show they then made Stargate
Atlantis they took some of the things
that maybe they didn't get quite right
from sg1 and they improved on them they
gave us characters that were well known
to us in lots of ways they gave us a
show that still felt like sg1 in lots of
ways they'd really fine-tuned the
formula that made Stargate sg1 brilliant
right now I'm about halfway through the
second season of Stargate Atlantis and I
am absolutely adoring watching it all
again it's been so long since I've got
to see Stargate Atlantis some of these
episodes I'd forgotten all about
and I cannot wait for what's coming next
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you think was SGA just that a
little bit better than sg1 now you look
back on it was it like I said the
formula for sg1 but fine-tuned was it in
lots of ways the perfect Stargate series
and more importantly that we never got
to see the Stargate Atlantis movie
Extinction again that is something I'm
going to talk about in a future video
and again get into the comments if you
want me to I would love to know what you
thought of SGA what were its strengths
what were his weaknesses and actually
out of the three different series of
Stargate what was your favorite get into
the comments and tell me exactly what
you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps resent and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel really helps keep
us going you get to see them without the
adverts and before everybody else you
even get a free gift after three months
can't say fairer than that
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]